Let's do some more work with
rational expressions.
So let's say I had a squared
plus 2ab plus b squared and
all of that is over ab squared
minus a squared b.
And we're going to take this
and divide it by a plus b.
So the first thing we might want
to do is just factor this
numerator and this
denominator, and
then we could divide.
Or actually, we could
go the other way.
We could divide and
then factor.
So if we divide and then factor,
we could say, well,
this is the same thing.
This is equal to this
whole expression.
Let me just copy and paste it.
That's probably the easiest
thing to do.
Copy and then paste it.
It's equal to that expression
times the inverse of this.
If I divide by something,
that's the same thing as
multiplying by the inverse,
as multiplying by
1 over a plus b.
And this is just going to be the
same thing as that with a
plus b in the denominator,
because your numerator's going
to be that times 1, which
is just that.
Your denominator is going to be
ab squared minus a squared
b times a plus b, so that
times a plus b.
So this would be a legitimate
answer, but I have a suspicion
that this can be further
simplified.
So let's see if we
can simplify it.
So our numerator, a squared plus
2 ab plus b squared, you
might recognize that.
That is a perfect square.
That is our numerator.
Let me color code it.
So that numerator right there,
that is the same thing as a
plus b squared, or a plus b
times a plus b, because you
have a squared, you have a b
squared, and then you have 2
times a and b right
in the middle.
That is a perfect square.
Multiply it out if you
don't believe me.
So that numerator is
that right there.
And then the denominator,
what is this?
Well, what happens if we factor
out an ab down here?
Let's factor out an ab.
So ab squared divided by ab, a
cancels out, you're just left
with ab, right? ab times b is
ab squared, and then minus a
squared b divided
by ab is just a.
This right here is the
same thing as that.
And you can multiply it out.
ab times negative a is
negative a squared b.
You got that right there.
So multiply it out.
You should get this
right there.
And, of course, you also have
your a plus b sitting here.
Now, we have an a plus b squared
in the numerator, we
have an a plus b into the
denominator, or we could say a
plus b to the first power.
And then we know our exponent
rules here.
We can just essentially cancel
out an a plus b in the
numerator and the denominator,
which decrements this exponent
by 1, so this just
becomes a 1.
And then this becomes a zero,
or it cancels out.
And so we get this is being
equal to a plus b over ab
times b minus a with the caveat
because we canceled
this thing out in
the denominator.
We have to say, look, this thing
could still not equal
zero, because this
will still make
this expression undefined.
We have to say the only way that
this is going to be equal
to zero is if we subtract b from
both sides, a is equal to
negative b.
So we have to add the caveat
that a cannot be equal to
negative b.
We have to add this condition.
So this is our answer.
Let's do another one.
Let's say I have-- let's do a
more involved one, just to
really get our juices flowing.
Let's say we have x squared plus
8x plus 16 divided by, or
over, 7x squared plus 9x plus 2
divided by 7x over 4 over x
squared plus 4x.
So what is this going
to be equal to?
So here we could divide first.
That's the same thing as
multiplying by the inverse
of this thing.
But just for fun, let's factor
these two, the numerator and
the denominator here.
So this numerator over here,
that's pretty straightforward.
That is a perfect square.
That is x plus 4 squared.
4 times 4 is 16.
4 plus 4 is 8.
So our numerator is
x plus 4 squared.
And then our denominator,
what does that become?
Here, we're going to have to do
a little bit of grouping to
factor that out.
So we have 7x squared
plus 9x plus 2.
We have to find two numbers.
When I multiply them, I get 7
times 2, which is equal to 14.
And when I add them, a
plus b, they equal 9.
And the easiest two numbers
are 7 and 2.
So let's rewrite this.
This is the same thing as 7x
squared-- I'll group the 7x
with the 7 because they have a
common factor of 7-- plus 7x
plus 2x plus 2.
I put parentheses around there
so you can see the grouping.
Factor out a 7x over here, you
get 7x times x plus 1 plus--
factor out a 2 here.
2 times x plus 1, and you get 7x
plus 2 times your x plus 1.
We're undistributing
that expression.
So this is our denominator
right there.
And actually, I just realized
that I made a slight error
when I wrote down
this problem.
The numerator here is actually
7x plus 2, lucky for us.
Obviously, this is going to
lead to interesting things
later on, potentially.
So let's see what we get.
And actually, I think
there's a typo here.
I think this is supposed to be
a 4x-- oh, sorry, just a 4.
So let me just put it like that
just in case that is a
typo because I think it's
going to make it more
interesting.
So that's our original
problem.
We haven't messed with this part
yet, so it won't change
any of our math.
But so far, we factored
this bottom part.
We factored this bottom part
using grouping as 7x plus 2
times x plus 1.
And so this expression is the
exact same thing as this
expression over here, and we're
going to divide it by
that expression.
So dividing by that expression,
that is the same
exact thing as multiplying
by the inverse of this
expression.
Actually, you know what?
I just realized that it wasn't
x squared plus 4x.
I just saw the problem.
That is an x squared plus 4x.
This was the original problem.
Sorry for all that.
We haven't done any work
here so it's all cool.
So this right over here,
multiplying by the inverse of
this, we multiply-- dividing by
this is the same thing as
multiplying by the inverse, so
we just flip the numerator and
the denominator.
So x squared plus 4x
over 7x plus 2.
And then another thing we can
do, if we look at this up
here, we can factor out an x.
So this right here, if we factor
out an x is the same
thing as x times x plus 4.
So if we do all of the
multiplication, what does our
numerator become?
We have x-- I'll use a new
color-- we have x plus 4
squared times x times
x plus 4.
That is our numerator.
And our denominator is 7x plus
2 times another 7x plus 2
times an x plus 1.
So here nothing is canceling
out, but we have the same term
being multiplied
multiple times.
x to the fourth squared times
x to the fourth to the first
power, this is going to be equal
to-- we still have our x
out front, so it's x times x
plus 4, we could say to the
third power, all of that over--
we have two 7x's plus
2, so 7x plus 2 squared
times x plus 1.
And we are done!